looking back it is the best decision
that I've ever made also the hardest
decision I've ever made in my entire
life and I do have an incredible
announcement to make
I am moving hey everyone welcome to
another episode of unlocking lily so I
believe that this world would be a
better place if we all just embrace who
we truly are and it is currently an
investor in my business and is mentoring
me to help me grow my coaching and
speaking practice and it's an absolute
honor to invite all of you guys to join
me on my startup journey guys I cannot
believe that it's been a year since I
started my journey in being an
entrepreneur I have so many mixed
feelings about this coz on one side I
feel like wow this time has gone by
really quickly and on the other side I
feel like I've been doing this for over
a decade because so many things has
happened I had my first TEDx dog I
started my coaching practice I hired my
first employee and I launched the School
of Life and has been quite the wild ride
let me just tell you so in this video I
am going to share with you all the
twists and the turns and the changes
that I've had over the last year and the
one important lesson that I have learned
throughout this entire experience that
is to bet on myself so over a year ago
Evan offered me something incredible
that is to be an investor and a mentor
in my business and my first initial
reaction was this is an opportunity of a
lifetime I cannot pass this up and on
the other side my logical side came in
right the logical side that said well
you have a very safe job right now you
have financial security you have bills
to pay you got a mortgage to pay you
have a husband to take care of why are
you going to do something
is crazy and I don't know what it was at
the time maybe it was just a right time
for me and I was ready I listened to my
heart you know that voice that tells you
to just do it do it do it do it do it
yes it's scary
yes it's uncomfortable you know what
life is gonna be amazing
don't you even worry about it and for
the first time in a very very long time
I decided to listen to that voice I
decided to finally take a bet on myself
and say yes and that's how this entire
journey began for me so in the beginning
I set out to be a speaker it was my
dream to stand on stage and speak in
front of thousands of people in helping
them transform their lives and at the
same time I had zero experience doing it
so I really needed to develop a plan for
myself and that's a thing when you an
entrepreneur starting out you're gonna
have these grand ideas and ambitions and
goals but you may not know the first
step towards it so when you don't know
where to begin the best place to start
is to model the Masters and that's
exactly what I did so I made a list of
20 speakers who I looked up to people
like Tony Robbins forename Brown and
simon Sinek
and I researched these three things the
first thing I looked at was I start what
are the things that they did in the
beginning of their journey and the
reason for that is you don't want to
look at what they're doing right now
when you're starting off in your journey
because it's going to be way too much of
a leap for you and in a lot of ways it
could be discouraging and you want to
make sure that you're as exciting and
encouraged as possible in the beginning
so knowing what they did in the
beginning is going to help you pave your
path the second thing I looked at was a
breakthroughs so what are the things
that they did to break them through to
who they are today and the reason for
that is there are multiple paths you can
take there multiple things you can do
but if you can zero in on those
breakthrough moments you could mimic
those and hopefully get you breakthrough
yourself
and the last thing I looked at was
monetization because as beautiful and
amazing it is to do things that you love
and are passionate about you also want
to make money from it because if you
don't make money from your business is
not a business it's a hobby and I set
out to create a business so knowing all
those three things I saw the common
patterns and I started off with my plan
so the first thing I needed to do was to
get lots of practice because that's what
Tony Robbins said you know you have to
practice over and over again to get good
so I said a thousand different places
and I started speaking in all of them
and just kept on getting practice and in
the beginning you're going to be doing
things for free and that's the humility
that you need in the beginning because
when you don't know what it is that
you're doing you have to take on
opportunities that you may think that
are beneath you but that's a humility
you need in the start and the second
thing I looked at was a breakthrough
so both simon Sinek and britney Brown
had TEDx talks and TEDx talk is
something I've always wanted to do as
part of my bucket list but knowing that
that's what they did I needed to do it
so I applied to 50 different places and
I got my first TEDx talk within the
first month of me starting my journey
and the last thing was a monetization
the common things that the speakers were
monetizing were books online courses and
coaching and I knew that writing a book
is not part of what I want to do at all
so that quickly dropped off my list and
I focused on coaching and the online
courses and that's a thing when you're
looking at the people that you're
inspired by there might be certain
things that they're doing right now that
doesn't resonate with you who's to say
that you have to follow all of those
things you could just pick a couple of
them that works for you so having those
plans in place I started off my journey
and I was so incredibly excited so I did
a lot of talks in the beginning of my
journey and as a parallel path I did my
coaching suggestion from Evan and as
well as I saw though a lot of the
speakers were doing that as well
and I had I had so much reservations
around coaching because it wasn't
something that I saw myself doing in
that moment it just didn't cross my mind
I wanted to make a huge impact in the
world and 101 wasn't something that
really made sense for me but I decided
to give it a try anyway so in the
beginning I started with a hundred free
coaching sessions because I just didn't
think was fair I don't think it was fair
for me to charge people when I wasn't
even sure if this is something I was
going to do in the long term but I did
it anyway and honestly that was the one
thing that I was completely wrong about
pretty quickly in my coaching practice I
realized that it brought me the most
fulfillment and joy share those special
moments of vulnerabilities of them
sharing their life stories their
struggles their challenges in the
beginning and to see them change see
them transform see them believe in
themselves even more and more every time
I saw them I didn't even know if there
was another feeling that great and
pretty quickly I decided to pivot my
business into focusing on coaching even
more and again I had doubts because I
went online and I said hey I want to be
a speaker as my dream to be a speaker
and for me to pivot my business
completely and announced that made me
feel like I was in flight E or I made me
feel like I kept on changing my mind
but once again I had to bet on myself
I needed this thing to work because I
knew this was right for me so I decided
to completely change my business around
and to focus way more of my hours to
coaching and slowly move away from the
speaking and that's a thing your
business is going to pivot usually the
thing that you start with is not the
thing you're going to end up doing and
that's okay you need to give yourself
the permission to know they're
constantly changing and growing and
sometimes that means that you didn't
walk away from certain things to focus
on other opportunities and that's okay
and you need to bet you on yourself that
way so while all of these amazing things
were happening in my business I also had
a lot of dark moments I questioned
myself every single day I had tons of
self-doubt I questioned my worthiness
and the value I was bringing into my
business and at one point I even thought
that I would quit and go back into the
corporate lifestyle that I was so used
to and at the same time I was struggling
with something huge that is I was I was
wondering if I should end my marriage
because it was just not working we just
simply were growing apart
and I was struggling with that decision
for many reasons one of those reasons is
the fact that I believed I had integrity
and for me to walk away from something
that was supposed to last a lifetime was
out of the question for me I wrote my
own vows
and that vows was to last all of
eternity not just two and a half years
and I also questioned myself and how can
I possibly help other people succeed in
their lives and help them
provide happiness and fulfillment in
their life when I can't even make a
marriage work so I went back and forth
for many many months but I also realized
something now what I really do is I help
people to find success on their own
terms
and sometimes success means that you
have to let go of something that you
feel obligated to words that could be a
relationship that could be a friendship
that could be a business idea
staying in something too long serves
nobody at all it doesn't serve you it
doesn't serve the people involved it
doesn't serve the world and I knew that
I had to do this for myself I knew that
I have to walk away from this and I did
I made the decision and looking back it
is the best decision that I've ever made
also the hardest decision I've ever made
in my entire life it made me feel like I
was literally about to die when I made
that decision and while I was going on
with thud and going through my
separation I had people counting on me
and that's exactly what I did the first
thing I did was I shared with Evan what
I was going through I wanted him to know
that this was the stage in my life and I
needed his help because this was
something that was really hard for me
and I couldn't do it alone and he was so
incredibly supportive and he helped me
through the entire process second person
that I reached out to was my assistant
because I wanted him to know that I may
not be around for long periods of time
because I was going through a really
difficult time in my life and of course
he was incredibly supportive and he said
that I
like family to him so anything I needed
he would provide for me and I also
reached out to my clients I made videos
for them and I told them listen I'm not
getting any sleep at all because of my
separation and it could mean the Hat I
might not answer your emails right away
I may drop the ball on certain things
and I want you to know that I still care
immensely about you and your business
but I'm going through this right now and
I need you to know and again incredibly
supportive not only they were the
understanding they'd went out of their
way to make me feel better by sending me
funny videos and doing all sorts of
things for me and it made me feel so
incredible and really out of this I
realized that not only was I able to get
through my separation period it made me
realize that this is something I was
meant to do this was my calling even in
my darkest moments I woke up every
single day and I continued on to work on
my business that further solidified my
passion and my excitement towards what I
was doing and that's a thing as an
entrepreneur you are going to go through
extremely difficult times you may go
through a divorce you may go through an
illness you may go through a death in
the family and the most important thing
is for you to be a hundred percent
honest with everybody involved because
it's not only about you anymore it's
about your employees it's about the
people that you're serving and again you
just have to trust in yourself and bet
on yourself that you are doing the right
thing and everything is going to just
fall into place
so the next chapter of my journey is
that I'm only going to bet on myself
even more if there's anything that I
have learned throughout this entire
experience as a fund but I need to
believe that I'm doing the right thing I
need to believe that I can follow my
heart and jump into the unknown it all
started when I said yesterday have been
a year ago and I started this journey I
jumped to the unknown when I did my
coaching I didn't know this is something
I wanted to do and thank me so much
happiness and I also jumped into the
unknown when I ended my marriage
something that was incredibly secure for
me and something else familiar with now
I ended that and who knows who I'm gonna
meet and fall in love with all I know is
I need to continue to follow my heart
and jump into known and bet on myself
and I do have an incredible announcement
to make I am moving to Mexico that's
right I made a heart decision to jumpity
unknown and I'm gonna make this business
work in Mexico so Evan I gonna continue
to work together we're gonna do remote
mentoring and we're gonna continue to
grow this business even bigger than it
is right now and have a special shout
out for Alessandra thank you so much for
being there for me since day one and
your support it means the world to me
thank you so much Alex and finally the
question of the day is what is that one
thing you are going to do to bet on
yourself write in the comments below and
I'll join in on the discussion thank you
guys so much for watching and more
importantly being on this journey with
me
it's been quite the year I have grown I
have changed and I'm gonna continue to
grow and change and it gives me the
comfort in knowing that you guys aren't
there for me every step of the way so
thank you so much again and I'll see you
guys very very soon bye bye
once all you have the most important
work ever if you had to think of one
word that's most important to you or
that sums you Apple
so it would be like a little beacon hey
believe nation if you want to know what
the most important one word is for Tony
Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey
will.i.am and Howard Schultz I have a
very special secret video for you check
the description for details